The Wall Street Journal has done a
report that a teacher in South Korea is
making four million dollars a year now
that would make you think that they put
a different emphasis on education than
we do here in the United States Kim Chi
hoon has been teaching for over twenty
years and he does these private ask
after school tutoring programs and he is
paid accordingly because he does a
really good job let's take a look at
some some facts about education
this is South Korea versus the United
States high school graduation rate in
the u.s. seventy-seven percent South
Korea 93 percent eighth graders ranked
advanced it's 7 percent in the u.s. 47
percent in South Korea and in 2012 the
u.s. spent 15 billion on video games
South Korea spent 17 billion on tutoring
services all right I mean it's hard to
argue with numbers like that so there's
a lot of ways we can go here but first
off do we just not put the right
emphasis on education in any way
whatsoever yeah I think I think
education is definitely like ripe for
disruption and it makes me really happy
to hear that an educator is being
appreciated you know in that way in
South Korea but on the other hand you
know the fact that there are so many
problems with education here in the US
has given rise to really innovative
startups like Khan Academy and the
amazing things that they're doing an
education or platform for a guy like Ken
Robinson to have the most viewed TED
talk of all time you know and his
thoughts on how education needs to be
like disrupted so um so yeah I mean I
think there's a lot of exciting things
going on in this country but yes to
answer your question is basically do you
think it's ever possible that we will
pay our educators like this guy I mean
this guy's basically being paid like a
basketball player or professional at I
mean I think that's I think it's really
cool but I think it does open up to kind
of a devil's advocate discussion too
which is about this guy gets paid really
well because he does private
after-school tutoring and only rich
people are able to buy seats in his
lecture halls only rich people are able
to buy individual downloads of his
lectures so I think that this model
although yes I would love to see
teachers
actually getting bonuses and teachers
being paid more for doing a good job and
not just like a static salary where
we're all teachers performances is put
into one pot and it doesn't really kind
of entice teachers to do a better job
because let's be real that is the one
variable in the classroom that actually
matters across almost everything else
having a really solid good teacher who's
invested in who cares is going to have
the biggest impact on the education of
the students but at the same time a
model like this could potentially just
increase the rift between the upper and
the lower classes in this country and we
already have a huge middle class problem
yeah so I can see this going either way
it's good point like either the rich
people are just gonna keep being able to
pay better teachers or because
everything the more it goes online and
the more people that get involved it's
sort of like health care that the hope
is you get more people in on it and
there's more resources and then it
ultimately gets cheaper but I guess more
competition there that people you know
this individual made news because he is
the most sought-after teacher in South
Korea that's why he's making four
million dollars but these are highly
competitive tutoring programs and so
there are a lot of people vying for
those spots there are lot of people
vying to make that much money so the
hope would be that even individuals who
maybe aren't as successful as this
individual teacher are able to pull in
you know a specific amount of money and
and for individuals might be able to put
their students into those after-school
programs but it really looks like it's
an issue of priorities the parents are
prioritizing different in that country
they're willing to put money into their
children's education over putting money
into you know make whatever we're
wasting our money on here right but is
there any I I'm a big video game guy I
used to work at electronics particular
Brad yes assistant manager you know um
but is there any risk in an overemphasis
I don't want to just focus on that like
is there any risk in an overemphasis on
education and that maybe we are getting
something here in the United States
because our kids do play a lot and play
video games about that let's play a lot
anymore what what are they I don't know
what the kids are doing
Instagram alone there is a grandma but
they're not I mean recess is getting cut
a lot of kids aren't you know parents
are too scared to let their kids play
outside we have like a massive childhood
obesity epidemic in this country yeah
obviously I think that we need to have a
well-rounded approach to education and I
think there's obviously a risk of being
too kind of totalitarian with the way
that you raise your children and forcing
education on them to an extent that you
don't like get enough hours of sleep at
night or that you don't get to exercise
so if if we found out that South Koreans
were much smarter than us and even more
productive but at the end of the day
we're not as happy because we don't I'm
just playing devil's advocate here for a
second but not as happy because we do
play whether it's outside or just
sitting on PlayStation do you think it's
it's a worth trade-off it's a worthy
trade-off uh happy happiness vers
happiness halogens um no I think that I
think intelligence is definitely or fee
not it's not even intelligence per se
because there's no way to even
standardize you know like one sort of
overarching intelligence quotient
obviously but um we should do our best
to provoke imagination amongst children
and sort of creative output and and you
know Malcolm clout Gladwell calls it
concerted cultivation you know putting
kids in as many sort of creative novel
environments as possible I think putting
too much emphasis on STEM education
could be problematic and that's sort of
like Ken Robinson's whole thing is that
we should be doing more to get children
to think creatively and I don't see I
don't see there being a conflict between
thinking creatively and having an
emphasis on STEM education I think we
should be changing the way that we
approach them education so that creative
thought is a part of STEM education you
think they're they're exactly equal do
you think that we should be teaching
them completely equally like sort of the
facts and then how to use the creative
partier brain I think that doing science
is ultimately using the creative part of
your brain you cannot be a successful
scientist without being a very creative
out-of-the-box thinker and I think what
a lot of people draw the analogy that
science is math and so you have to be
great a minute I can be good at science
you know like it's a very sort of a
favorite work it's a creative endeavor I
think that if we start students
understanding math theory and not just
memorizing
times tables I think that there's a
better approach there too that's a
totally different
but well it reminds me of you know how
Albert Einstein who you know prior
greatest scientist ever uh you know
couldn't tie his shoes you know like he
could like probably highly autistic
probably probably but the fact that he
had trouble doing sort of daily simple
tasks and because his brain was
operating in a whole other realm that a
few of us ever get to yeah although if
you smoke some of that pot that we
talked about earlier in the show I guess